the this morning's tutorial for the
bootcamp Oh will be on lower bound
techniques in proof complexity and Pablo
Rupesh will give good morning so I'll be
talking about lower bounds in proof
complexity I'll tell you a little bit
about what proof complexity is about so
it depends probably the motivation
depends on which background you would
come from but like I originally studied
mathematical logic where the key
question is the following you have a
proof system P and you want to know
which theorems are provable in that
system in proof complexity you ask a
different question
you have a proof system you know that
something is provable in the system you
know and you want to know how hard it is
to prove something in the system how
short are the proofs or ronk are the
proofs of whatever you are interested in
now if you are background is computer
science then the motivation should be
that in computer science you are
interested in how hard is it to compute
something here we are interested in how
hard is it to prove something now the
central object that people study in this
context is the so called propositional
proof system which is abstractly defined
as follows so in your proof system
something as a proof and you are
interested in proof systems that prove
propositional tautologies so something
has a proof only if it is a
propositional tautology that's one
property that you demand from it and the
second property that you require is that
if somebody gives you proof you can
actually check efficiently whether the
proof is a correct proof or not so this
is an abstract definition but I'll give
you some examples so my favorite example
is the so called Fraga system
favorite system I think of everybody
else's resolution then another proof
system I'll talk about a bit is called
the cutting planes and another example
would be the set of C which is a very
abstract theory which proves a lot of
things about large guard innocent or not
proofs things about large carbonyls but
if you restrict ZFC only to talk about
propositional tautologies what it could
prove in propositional logic it also
becomes a proof system and as such is
probably the most powerful system that
we so far know the pregger system looks
as follows so it's the usual textbook
axiomatization of propositional calculus
now it depends which textbooks you have
so what do I have to oxi matters it is
the following if only one rule which
says that from a implies B and a you can
infer B which means that if you have
proved a implies B and you have proved a
you can also prove B and then you have a
bunch of axioms and vaccines are as
follows
now this doesn't look very appealing
because for example I don't remember
what the axioms exactly are and I'm not
on a person sure if I didn't add one
extra axiom or didn't forget some axiom
but at the point of this is that the
definition is very robust so if you
decide to add an extra axiom like for
example I think the axiom a or not a
a or not a a or not a is not among these
things but if I decide to edit as an
extraction the power of the system in
terms of the length of proofs stays
pretty much the same it changes only by
a constant factor similarly if I decide
to add some more connectives like parity
gates or your favorite boolean function
and add a bunch of new axioms governing
this new connective the strength of the
system stays the same so it's a very
very robust system and as such it's very
nice to work with yeah basically but
sort of if I did there is a actually
this is an example of a Fraga system but
there is a notion of general class of
systems which is called Fraga systems
which have the property that you have a
final list of axioms of this kind and
finite list of inference rules and
that's called Fraga systems and then you
can show them in terms of lengths of
proofs all of those frege's systems are
equivalent and also that so if there is
a proof in one there is a proof in
another and if there is a short proof in
one there is a short proof in another
but the abstract definition would take
too long for me to
so that's the Fraga system another
system is resolution and resolution is
actually not a proof system as I did
find it but it's a refutation system so
instead of proving that something is the
tautology which means it's satisfied by
every assignment you prove that
something is a contradiction that it's
never satisfied and you also work only
with unsatisfiable CNF so the resolution
system looks as follows
so the basic objects that resolution
works with our clauses which are just
these junctions or variables or their
negations and for simplicity you just
think of the disjunction as a set of
variables and their negations and you
have only one resolution rule which says
that from you can start with two clauses
if this one has a variable and that one
is a negative variable you can remove
the variable and form the union so
that's the only rule and a resolution
refutation of a set of clauses is that
you start with your clauses that you
want to refute and you form new clauses
by the resolution rule until you reach
the empty clause which is obviously an
service so that's what a resolution
refutation is sometimes it's more
convenient actually to think about
resolution refutations in terms of trees
or in terms of graphs so you resolution
refutation starts you start with your
initial clauses c1 through cm those are
the things you want to refute and then
you form new clauses from the initial
clauses by the resolution rule and then
you can combine them again combine them
again until you reach the empty clause
which is unsatisfiable and this provides
a witness for unsatisfiability order
[Music]
Oh
and similarly if you are talking about
CNF so a CNF which is a conjunction of
disjunction is unsatisfiable sorry so a
refutation of a CNF is just a refutation
of the clauses or appearing in the CNF
so one
Gordan observation about the resolution
proof system is that it is sound and
complete meaning that if you manage to
refute a set of clauses then the clauses
are actually unsatisfiable and if a set
of causes is unsatisfiable then actually
there exists a resolution refutation
this is a fairly simple proof but I will
not not show
I will talk a lot about resolution
because in terms of what people can
prove the resolution is the weakest most
end and the same time interesting proof
system so at the same times it's
interesting and you can also prove a
bunch of things about it so a resolution
will appear a lot in this talk so
another example that I'll mention a
little bit will be cutting planes which
looks a little bit like resolution
except the objects that it works with
are not closes that is division
junctions but there are linear
inequalities with integer coefficients
and you can think of representing a
clause in terms of linear inequality or
equal to one which is clearly over zero
one assignments those two expressions
are equivalent so you think of
translating clauses that is disjunctions
as linear inequalities and you have a
bunch of rules now you have new rules
which are sort of evident the first one
is once you have derived an inequality
you can multiply it by a non-negative
number and the outcome is still valid
you can add two inequalities that the
second rule and interesting rule is the
rounding rule which basically tells you
that you are working with the variables
are intended to be integers so like one
application of the rule would be suppose
that you have some somewhere derived to
X is greater or equal to one and suppose
I intend to work
integers so I know that X is an integer
so if X is greater or equal to one this
means that X must be at least one okay
because X is an integer so it is the
third rule that guarantees that we are
working with inequalities over integer
valued variables
the cutting points refutation is what
you would expect so you start with the
inequalities the initial inequalities
and you obtain new inequalities by means
of the three previous rules until you
get a contradiction that zero is greater
or equal to one guarantees in this case
this would guarantee that the original
inequalities we have have no integer
solutions however I'm interested in
proposition tautologies that is in the
zero one assignments through variables
so if I'm talking about a CNF and I want
to say that the CNF s is unsatisfiable
meaning it is no zero one solutions not
only that you have no integer solutions
then what you will do you will take the
clauses in the CNF you will form their
translations into linear inequalities
but you will also add the boolean axioms
saying that every variable is between 0
& 1 as additional axioms
and one can proof that again cutting
plants is completing the following
summon completing the following sense
that if a formula has a cutting plane
refutation then it is unsatisfiable and
if it is unsatisfied and it also has
cutting plane
which I have to show that you can do
with emotion
yes okay this is actually the
completeness of Kanna class is an
interesting issue and I am omitting
references but to prove this theorem
it's enough to show that cutting planes
simulates resolution so I already showed
you how to translate translate an
inequality a clause into an inequality
so you revise replace X or Y or not Z as
the quality above so if you take a
resolution refutation and you apply this
translation line by line you will get
the cutting planes refutation
so cutting planes simulates resolution
so that's one way how to prove
completeness on the other hand when
collateral designed this system
originally he was not talking about CNF
formulas but about general sets of
linear inequalities over integers and
there there is also completeness theorem
saying that if a set of linear
inequalities has no integer solutions
then it also has a cutting planes
refutation but that proof is much much
more complicated and you cannot obtain
it by reduction to resolution because
resolution talks only about zero one
solutions similarly if you talk about a
set of linear inequalities which are not
translations of clauses then also the
proof is not more difficult so I'm
making my life easy in this statement by
assuming that the clauses I am working
with our translations of
and
so there are some examples of like proof
systems I will talk about Fraga system
resolution cutting planes and now back
to the original question of what people
want to do improve complexity so it's
another definition so I have a proof
system which can be one of the systems I
previously described and the question
you want to know whether there are some
hard formulas which better there are
hard formulas to prove in the system so
you want to know in particle whether
there exists a polynomial such that
every polynomial size formula every
formula of size s has proof of size
polynomial in s in that system okay so
that system we would call polynomial
bound it's a system in which every thing
has a short proof now the basic question
that you ask in proof complexity is that
given a your favorite proof system P is
that system polynomial bound there's
basically the question or in other words
you want to show that the system is not
polynomially bounded meaning that there
exists a tautology which is hard to
prove in the system which is which
requires super polynomial size proofs
and the general belief is that no
polynomially bounded proof system exists
because by the following theorem
polynomially bounded proof system exists
if and only if NP is equal to one so in
general any system you think of as long
as it satisfies the definition of the
propositional proof system should not be
polynomially bounded to see this is
quite straightforward so basically the
definition of propositional proof system
means the following it is a proposition
proof system is a non-deterministic
Turing machine which is supposed to
solve the quantum complete problem which
is of deciding whether something is a
tautology so it's a non-deterministic
Turing machine solving a can't be
complete problem and the fact that it's
polynomial bound it means that the
non-deterministic Turing machine runs in
non-deterministic polynomial time which
means that there exists a polynomially
bounded proof system if and only if NP
is equal to n point P it's just an
application of the definition
nevertheless it means that for the
systems that I mentioned before they
should not be polynomially bounded
unless I can't and I don't think it's
possible I don't think well if NP is
equal to Kunti and you show me a very
simple proof that NP is equal to can't
be then maybe later I'll be able to
adopt the proof to construct some nice
process
machinima and megasis things appear
proof are are instantaneous descriptions
of a computation or something like this
sure yes but like I thought you mean
nice like nice pull a spawn set like the
tape of the machine would be like lines
on your proofs and then the positions on
the tape so it would be local because
during machines are it wouldn't look
like what we if your definition of nice
is being provable in the
so here are some classical results that
people know so resolution system as I
defined it is not polynomial about it so
there are things which are hard to prove
in resolution that's good
this little thing is true for cutting
planes and another thing is true for
bounded depth Franken
I didn't define what Bonnie left
breakables but I define what Fraga was
so imagine that you have Frogger as we
had before
but you insist that all the formulas
appearing in the proof have constant
depth let's say a hundred otherwise the
rules would be pretty much the same we
are working with formulas of bounded
depth and for that I type prove that
bounded depth Frogger
is also not exponential about it I will
not talk about this result but if you
become interested this is probably the
most interesting and by far the
strongest result in proof complexity
ever this is the gem of proof complexity
and it was proved like 30 years ago and
it's still the general and improved code
base it's rather involved and I will not
talk about it but there are many more
proof systems for the which is for which
this is not not for example for Fraga
system we don't know so the main open
problem would be is the Fraga system
polynomially bounded so for all that we
know it could be the case that every
tautology has a polynomial size Fraga
proof this
it's us for some more details so when
you said well forgive you described it
as a implies B and a buys a separate set
of what type of objects are a we are n B
formula yes infrakit
and B are formulas there is no explain
that better but so Fraga had like rules
like axioms like a implies B implies a
the meaning of this is that it is a it's
not a single axiom it's a scheme so for
a you are allowed to substitute anything
you want so we are allowed to let's say
if x and y are variables so you're
allowed to use this as an axiom so any
instance of this whatever you substitute
for M be like this for example is also
an axiom which you can use in your proof
and similarly for all the other axioms
now when measuring there are different
ways out to measure the size of the
proof but the size of the proof would be
just the size of each application of the
axiom in the proof
and when you say it's bounded depth a we
have to be bounded yes
and of course bounded that would mean
with conjunctions and disjunctions of
arbitrary fennan the rules I stated
before were on only for selling too but
you can easily adapt it - yeah I wanted
to say that but then I realized I never
remember but it's a C or a CC and but
the motivation for bounded that frigate
so you can think of iodized lower bound
is like a really sophisticated way how
to translate lower bounds on boolean
circuits of bounded depth into the
language of proof complexity so there is
a lower bound for money the circuits for
parity and now you sort of extend and
adapt and work a lot to use this lower
bound for proofs which work only with
bounded after circuits or formulas
[Music]
and the way how those results go is that
you favorite CNF that people work with
is the so-called pigeonhole principle
which is an unsatisfiable CNF which says
that there is an injection from n plus 1
so here the size of n plus 1 and you
think of the variables X IJ saying that
the 8th pigeon goes to Jeff oh and now
we have a bunch of clauses which say
that so there is this big clause which
says that for every I there exists an J
such that X IJ is true which means that
every pigeon goes to some home so that's
the first clause and then you have
clauses which say that for every hole
it's not true that there are two pigeons
sitting in the hole so that's a CNF
which is trying to assert that there is
an injection from set of size n plus 1
to a set of size n which is clearly
unsatisfied so that's a nice answered
satisfiable CNF and the robot for
resolution goes by saying that
pigeonhole principle is actually an
example of a hard thing to refute in in
a resolution
I die slower bond that I mentioned
before is that pigeonhole principle
requires exponential size bounded at
Fraga proof now I apologize about the
negations because resolution is a
refutation system and you're refuting
think and Fraga system is a system where
you're proving I invented but it's
confusing
but when you want to prove romance for
stronger proof systems the general
principle no longer works so you can
show that the pigeonhole principle as
stated has short refutation in the full
Fraga system and it also has a short
levitation in the cutting planes proof
system so in the overview of the
classical results I'm sloppy with
references so actually I type prove the
super polynomial rubber bands for
pigeonhole principle which was later
improved by poll and to truly
exponential robots and also simplify the
proof quite a lot original proof of idea
is beautiful but completely
incomprehensible cutting planes we do
know lower bounds so for cutting planes
there is a modification of the
pigeonhole principle for example that I
will talk about which is hard for
cutting planes which is the same
principle except you encode it in a
slightly different way which will work
in cutting planes for Fragger that's a
very interesting question
so like coming up with hard candidates
for Fraga system is a good question I
don't know about many the only thing I
know I think the the following tautology
so which comes from algebra so suppose
you have two matrices a times B
Esper matrices that a times B is the
identity so that means that B times a so
yes and let's say we are working over GF
2 to make life easier so that we don't
have to worry how to encode numbers in
as boolean strings so GF 2 this is
clearly a tautology but as far as I know
the the best upper bound on the size of
proofs of this is quasi-polynomial in n
so this is one possible candidate to
prove lower bounds for fraggin but if I
were to conjecture I would guess that
this is actually easy in Fraga and you
should probably spend time to prove an
upper bound in flag and show that you
can prove this by polynomial size proof
but I don't know this so this might be
hard for fritz
N squared but this depends on how you
measure the proof size so if you are
interested in the total size of a proof
then then the the lower bound is N
squared if you are interested in the
number of lines then the lower bound is
n or maybe oh and the I will tell you
what the lower bound is and you will see
how silly it is so you take just some
favorite tautology that you have which
will be just the constant one and then
you add a bunch of negations in front of
it
make an even number of negations and now
you will ask frigate system to prove
that this is actually equal to one and
and since the roots in the fracas system
are sort of local so the the system can
read that most like one two negations at
a time so this will require if like the
number of negations years and this will
require roughly n lines to prove in the
system but each line will be roughly of
size M because that's what's going on
here yes yes on the number of lines is
linear if you are measuring the total
size its quadratic and it's sort of
silly
so like one open problem is for fragrant
to prove a lower bound we decide to
measure the number of inferences meaning
the number of lines and to prove them to
prove soup linear lower bounds like
something I think the official open
problem is n to 1 plus epsilon over
bound but I don't think that even n
Times log n or something is known so
that would be an open problem
but the exact trigger trigger system up
to polynomials yeah it's a kind of
tedious like with formula over bombs
okay so if you if you prove super
polynomial or amounts on formulas then
it doesn't matter what basis you are
working with but if you prove like
really we cannot abandon it mattress
over which basis you are working so for
Fraga if you prove superpolynomial
around it doesn't matter if you prove
something this week you have to fix your
system so it's like this lower bound
works for any frigate that you have this
is
but I don't look but not determined
that's a very interesting question so
whether there is a connection between
proof complexity lower bounds for Fraga
and circuit lower bounds so as far as I
know there is no like direct one-to-one
connection between the two
but you can show that if you prove for
lower bounds of a certain form for Fraga
then you will get circuit lower bounds
but unconditionally I don't know this if
you're just doing mine some of your
lines and pray you get exponentially
long so you'd have to be careful just
counting wise it's like extended rigor
yes that's true there are like other
proof systems like extended Frakker
which actually would capture the number
of lines and love the size anyway before
I guess I moved to the like the lower
bound techniques
let me make like two like general
observations about the proof complexity
so one think which is strange one thing
which is strange is that for Fraga
system and actually for most true
systems that I haven't mentioned we
don't know how to proof robots so we
don't know whether they are polynomially
bounded or not
which is a little bit weird because the
fixed proof system like Fraga is just
like an specific non-deterministic to
Domitian so now if you are in the
situation that somebody comes to and
gives you an algorithm and he says this
algorithm sort of sat in polynomial time
then usually you will find the back
eventually and you will see that I do it
doesn't so sad or it does not render an
important enough time and and you will
find it pretty soon but if I come to you
and say flag is polynomially bounded
meaning that everything is a short proof
in fragrant it's very hard to prove me
wrong even though it's a very similar
situation and the reason is only because
the Fraga system is a non deterministic
Turing machine so it's the non
determinism which is the hard part
so one particle formula can have many
many different proofs and you want to
say that among all this infinite you do
possible proofs none of them is short
that's like the problem so even for for
specific proof systems the question of
is it polynomially bounded or not is a
hard question typically that's one
observation the second observation is
that the field of proof complexity
contains many proof systems I mentioned
three so far but there are at least like
fifty more proof systems which are well
studied in literature and if you just
decide to invent your own proof system
probably you will invent proof system
which nobody else has studied before
and a lot of those proof systems are
comparable in the sense that if you have
short proof in one then you have a short
that you can simulate one by another so
if you have short proves in this one you
will have short proofs in that one but
you don't know the converse but a lot of
them are totally incomparable we don't
know what's the relationship with them
so there are like a lot of systems and
if you prove a lower bound on one then
you don't know anything about what's
going to happen in the other one
etc so this can be a little bit
frustrating because you are working in
one little thing which at the end like
implies nothing about other things but
potentially if you are like trying to
find interesting problems to work on
published some papers then this is also
nice because you can find some your
favorite crew system about which you can
prove something but why does it happen
like this doesn't happen in let's say
circuit complexity okay in circuit
complexity we should be probably all
agree that like boolean circuit that's
the one computational model or during
machine modelers that we really care
about and the other models of
computation we introduce it's out of
necessity because we cannot prove things
about boolean circuits so we define some
restrictions improve complexity is a
different situation and one reason I
guess is because that there is no or we
don't know whether there is an optimal
proof system which is some system which
would simulate all the proof systems so
when I mentioned the set of C proof
system
it probably simulates all the proof
systems we know because as
mathematicians we work in sort of C but
we don't know whether the set of C proof
system simulates every possible
propositional process and it's an open
problem whether there exist some
universal proof system or not if such a
proof system existed then we could all
talk about this one.beautiful proof
system and try to proof lower bounds for
that but we don't even know that such a
system exists and
it's actually believed that such a
system does not exist that it's
necessary to have many different proof
system so now I will move resorption and
our
let's give a sketch for the lower bound
for resorption proof system but in fact
I think all the proof sketches over
lower bounds I will give will be for
resolution because it's a is the
simplest proof system and if you have
some beautiful idea about how to prove
lower bounds then the idea should better
work for resolution if you make it work
for resolution maybe you will make it
work for something else so as then
illustration how lower about techniques
work or might work resolution is a good
testing ground
actually I will give a proof which I'd
consider like the simplest how to prove
one for resolution but I'm not
understand sure that this will turn out
to be the case and it's a proof which
comes from Benson and with Gerson which
in turn is based on earlier ideas of
Benson and Russell and many others
so first few different definitions so if
you have a clause which is a disjunction
of variables so you define its width as
simply the number of variables in in the
clause literal I guess I haven't defined
literal means a variable or its negation
so width of a clause is just the size of
the clause the next thing you consider
is the width of a resolution proof the
width of a resolution proof is the size
of the largest clause appearing in the
in the proof
finally this w bar will be the smallest
K such that you can refute the set of
clauses see in width at most K
and the the theorem is the following
if you have a set of courses C which
contain any variables then the number of
[Music]
the smallest K out its most yeah it's
true billion over then yes the smallest
sorry at most it's the smallest confused
but do you know do you know what it
means so you take a fixed refutation you
find the largest close call it k and
then you take the minimum of all the
reputations of an overall case okay just
change that
no no everyone so here's a theorem of
Memphis on immigration that that you can
lower bound the size of a resolution
refutation here by size I mean just the
number of lines in the refutation number
of applications of the resolution rule
is at least this quantity in in practice
what you will do is that you will start
with a set of clauses which themselves
will have a pretty small width so
ideally like three cns so we all have
closest which everything is with at most
three so this number is pretty small it
will be a constant now if you are
working in n variables potentially the
number of clauses the the width of a
clause in n variables can be up to n and
if you manage to show that when you
start with those really small clauses
like of size three then in every
refutation there has to be like a pretty
big claws like a clause of size let's
say n over two and in every refutation
there will be a close of size at least n
over two for example then you plug it
into that bound and you will get a lower
bound of like n over two squared over N
which is like N and you will get a lower
amount of 2 to the N so this is the idea
if if every refutation must contain a
big claws then you must have a large
refutation
now there is a different version of the
statement which is a little bit better
for tree-like proofs now tree-like
proofs I'll discuss later tree-like
proof in a resolution means that if you
look at this graph of the proof the
graph is actually a tree meaning that
once you have derived something you can
apply you can use it at most once and
you are not allowed to recycle it
general resolution proves don't look
like tree like proofs trailered proofs
are simpler to understand and also the
lower bound you are getting is better
sociologists to make sure I understand W
is just the maximum cross length can be
input instance should I ride the
confusing definition again or a bit so I
was planning on proving this the proof
is not difficult but I don't think I
will get to it I will instead I'll show
you an application of this slower mount
the so far it looks only like a
reduction of size of proofs to like the
notion of width but the point of this
reduction is that it's much easier to
understand with than science and it's
actually easy to come up with examples
of CN FS which require large width one
example is the bit pigeonhole principle
so remember the pigeonhole principle I
had before yes generally I don't think
so but there are like tricks okay I have
to do that so now the general principle
I will now talk about different version
but pigeonhole principle as I defined it
originally you cannot really apply this
bound because you are already starting
with clauses which are too huge
so that's not going to work that's why I
will modify it a little bit but what
Anoop is asking is whether there is some
black box may how to do this I don't
know about it but for pigeonhole
principle there is a trick how to do it
so here is your pigeonhole principle and
the problem is with the wide clauses
there is a clause for every pigeon which
says that it goes to at least one hole
which contains n variables now let's
instead fix some particle graph which
will be sparse and instead of saying
every pigeon must go to some hole here
let's say that this pigeon goes just to
the neighborhood of this point in this
graph and if the graph is sparse then
you will end up with CNF sub small width
and if you choose your graph cleverly
meaning an expander graph then actually
the lower bound will go through so there
is a trick that you can apply to the
pigeonhole principle
the bit pigeonhole principle looks as
follows so you will have huge matrix
besides two to the n plus one times M
and
and the CNF will say that all the rows
in this matrix are distinct which is
clearly a contradiction because there
are at most 2 to the N 0 1 rows that you
can build out of n and here we have 2 to
the n plus one of these so in particular
you will have variables for the entries
of the matrix and now for given two
distinct rows of the matrix you will
have a two CNF which says that the given
two rows are distinct I will leave it up
to you to write down the to it to and
CNF it's obvious such a CNF exists
because you are talking about 2n
variables yep and the bit PHP just says
that all the rows of this matrix are
distinct now the reason why I call it a
bit PHP is that there is a different way
out to think about it so think about it
as a pigeonhole principle from n plus 1
to n as we had before
but now instead of having a variable
which tells me where does the ice pigeon
go to you will have a variable which
gives you the bit representation of the
hole that the pigeon that that the
pigeon ghost so you can think of the
variable X IJ as giving you the J's bit
of the hole that the 8th pigeon cost so
it's the same sort of pigeonhole
principle except that you are not giving
the function as its graph but in terms
of the bit representation advantage here
is mainly that you have all together
[Music]
exponentially many variables to to the M
but the clauses are relatively narrow
the clauses have like look M variables
where n is the total number of
and
so if we if this makes sense I just want
to apply this bound and I hope it
doesn't upset you too much so if you
handle this smaller than okay then it
will not upset you that this n is
different than the N over there
so n over there is the total number of
variables this and it's just my
parameter and so I hope so
the way how its defined the width of the
initial process is 2n is pretty small
and now I want to say that the width of
the pigeonhole principle that every
refutation of the bit pigeonhole
principle must contain at least n minus
1 clauses capital n minus 1 costs and
it's very easy to see
only not in the next three minutes the
schedule of the argument would be the
following so assume that you have like
your refutation
and you have those initial clauses which
are there
and now if you have a cross see you you
think about how many pigeons do the
close talks about so remember that like
the bit pigeonhole principle I think
about it as saying that given a variable
X IJ which are the variables I think of
it as giving me the J's bit of the hole
corresponding to the earth pigeon so you
say that MC is the set of pigeons
he talks about
meaning that it contains some variable
that man mentions the pigeon and I want
to claim that in every refutation
there exists a clause which talks about
which talks about at least
so no matter what refutation you have if
it is a correct refutation there will be
some clause which contains and the proof
is very you should leave it as an
exercise but basically so have your
refutation and what you do is that you
construct a path which starts from the
empty clause
add some initial claws and for every
every close on the path you construct so
given the clothes in this part you
construct some partial injection which
is a partial injection from the number
of pigeons that the clause talks about
into N and this injection will have the
property that actually the close VI if
you evaluate it on this injection is
actually false
so the variables in P I talked about
pigeons and some bits of the holes that
the pigeon is is moved to now you will
construct a particle injection which is
from the set of pigeons that talks about
into n such that the clauses force
we're how you do that is that you do it
inductive so I'm
so this condition says that every pigeon
that the close bi talks about is mapped
somewhere by the injection which means
that every variable in that clause is
totally determined by my injection so I
just evaluate the clause on this on this
row and it means that it's false so you
substitute zeros ones and you get zero
so it's important that everything that
the Clause talks about is completely
determined by the injection now to
construct this is you start with p0 and
this row 0 will be just empty because
this original thing talks about nothing
now
you have already constructed like PII
somewhere if you have already
constructed BI somewhere here and now
look at how was it formed in your
resolution proof so it could be formed
by resolution of two clauses like C
now we already have an injection which
makes this false okay now now look at
the pigeon which is resolved here so
this caused those two clauses talk about
the pigeon L now if L is a pigeon which
P I already talks about what you do is
that you simply this is false
under the injection you already have
which means that at least one of the two
things must be false in the junction in
the injection the resolution works so
and at least one of the things must be
false so you just if this is false let's
say so you just inject you extend this
the path over here that's one thing and
and that's important you take the
restriction of your function to the set
of pigeon this clause talks about so you
guarantee the property that this is
false and and you have an injection from
the number of pigeons into another case
is that if you are in the case that L is
actually a pigeon that this does not
mention so now I am assuming I haven't
told you I'm working by contradiction
I'm assuming that every clause is
shorter than n minus one now if this is
actually shorter it talks about less
than at most n minus one pigeons then
there is one value I haven't used I can
extend the injection to this one extra
pigeon and again I'm in the situation
that at least one of the two things will
be false I moved to this one which is
false and I restrict the injection so I
never exceed a minus one in in the
calculation now now that you have that
this is a contradiction because when you
get to an initial cross the initial cost
should be false
under the injection I've constructed but
the initial cross talks only about two
pigeons and it says that the two pigeons
are distinct now
I've constructed an injection so the two
points are distinct and the initial
Clause is actually true which is a
contradiction so that means that every
refutation of the BIP internal principle
must contain it must contain a clause
which talks about at least n minus 1
pigeons proving this bound if this is
confusing think about it for three
minutes and it will be clear and finally
if you just plug it into this formula so
this is like capital and this is like
small n which is like log N and this n
is the total number of variables which
is like n capital n times m and you get
a lower bound on this size so that's
that's it for
that's just you are not coming back so
yeah I guess we can we'll have let's say
questions at the beginning what should
we do questions now or just take a break
down - yeah okay so let's start again at
11:00
[Applause]
[Music]